Hello everybody. Hope that you're good.
This is a new update, more like a
follow-up update from yesterday's video.
So, if you haven't watched it yet, then
I would suggest you to go and watch it
first and then come back to this video.
Um, there has been some movement, some
volatility, and I like to show up when
when that happens, when there is
movement because I can answer those
questions you might have that you've
been asking me on Telegram or on X and
also maybe we can add some setups so and
and mention some new setups. So let's
get started. The first thing is Bitcoin.
Bitcoin on Sunday we were mentioning at
110K.
So in this area here we were mentioning
that you know this could be some kind of
a range. This is your range highs your
range lows marking the 100% of this long
week which by the way this week it's in
Binance. Yes. But it's also in by in
binex in Bjet in Bluffin in Kcoin in
Mex. See, it's everywhere except on
Coinbase. So, we're going to consider
that there is enough liquidity to
consider this a real week all the way to
102K. All right. So, basically, when
price goes back to the 50% of the week
like it did yesterday, that means that
it's likely that it goes all the way to
the 100% of the week. All right. So,
we're going to be watching that level
102K,
potentially 101K because we could expect
to sweep the lows of that long week.
Okay, that's my main scenario at the
moment since Sunday and especially how
it's been playing out throughout the
week. But yeah, I'm kind of expecting a
sweep of the lows there of that long
week. Also at the level we'll have the
weekly 50 MA which is a you know a
strong bull market support and it's a
level where we could see some kind of a
of a bounce especially because you know
traders are getting very tired they're
getting frustrated.
All right you know you have this kind of
price action sideways while the alcoin
markets keep going down people are
getting tired and when that happen you
see relief rallies. Okay. So to spot the
a level where a relief rally could
happen my via is that around 102k but
more towards 101k or even 100k. All
right psychological level again you have
three confluences. You have a range that
will be a deviation below the range
lows. That's the first confluence.
Second confluence you would be feeling
the 100% of this long week. And the
third confluence is that you have the
weekly 50 MA sitting there. Let's go to
the weekly time frame. Look at it guys.
Okay, you have the weekly 50 MA bull
market support right there at 101K. So
that's a level of interest where we
could see a relief rally from today.
There has been some movement well
yesterday in the S&P 500. And this is
something that we mentioned also
yesterday. All right, it's happened
straight away. You have here notice
resistance, okay, and resistance as a
very clear resistance. Price manages to
break through, then retest a level of
support, continues going higher. And
look what you got here, guys. Again,
resistance and resistance. Okay, very
clear resistance. Price breaks through,
then comes back down, retest that
resistance as support. Okay, now the
question is if it's going to bounce from
here or if it's going to go lower, okay,
towards this level here towards 6,650
or so. But this down, it's a 1% candle,
daily candle, which is quite big for the
for the stock market. Okay, then of
course, Bitcoin followed although
Bitcoin was already going down. All
right, but this is how we find
confluences to analyze where the price
of Bitcoin could go. Now, if you jump
into alcoins, we first go to Ethereum.
Okay, 4 hours time frame. Let's look for
some setups. Yesterday, by the way, on
Telegram last night, I mentioned some
levels, some proof estimates where we
could see Ethereum and Solana going if
Bitcoin those go finally to 101K, 102K.
Okay? So, I invite you to join the the
Telegram channel. It's in the
description. It's free. All right? And
I'm way more active there than than on X
at the moment. So, I see you there. I
guess basically with Ethereum
uh on Sunday night on Telegram I shared
this chart you know we were at 3,800
3,900
I was expecting to you know hit all
these stop losses in this area you can
see that you have some lows here okay
one two three four lows a lot of
liquidity in this area building okay so
that was the first scenario to drop all
the way to that liquidity to those stop
losses and then if price managed to go
back above the range lows then that
would be a safe trigger. However, you
can see that the range lows acted as
resistance dropping price even lower.
Okay, and that take us to the next
scenario that is this one here that is
also sweeping the lows of this long
week. Okay, same as Bitcoin roof
estimate
again very rough estimate 3360
perhaps it's where it could go. Okay. Um
again in the case that Bitcoin does go
down to 101K 102K. All right. Um and
it's a rough estimate. My strategy here
will be watching Bitcoin. See if Bitcoin
makes that move. And once Bitcoin makes
the move all the way to 101K, 102K and I
can see some kind of reaction from
there, that's when I can start jumping
into longs in Ethereum, Solana, okay,
and others. Uh but yeah, basically rough
estimate 3,360 I would say. Now, if you
go to Solana, the same a lot of
liquidity below this trend line. You
have a short video also posted on my
YouTube channel from yesterday how we
trade these trend lines and and this
liquidity and how traders get
manipulated and how they lose money.
Okay. But again with Solana let's put
the three days time frame. Okay.
Uh no daily time frame sorry. I have
here some levels marked, but my roof
estimate
my roof estimate
would probably be around 147
150. Okay, that's my roof estimate for
Solana if Bitcoin pulls down more low.
Okay, and then there are some charts
that seem quite interesting. One of them
is I don't know how you say this one,
ENA or ENA, right? If you go to the 3
days time frame, this one I remember I
took a beautiful trade that I was
supposed on X back at the time and it
was here. I built longs between 0.25
and 35. Okay. And then I at 0.84. I
remember exactly because it was right at
the top. H look
also I saw here some resistance as you
can see. But uh yeah, kind of lucky
because that was exact top pretty much
and then price dropped. Now this
structure is a structure that I'm seeing
quite a lot in some charts in some
altcoin charts and you see here like a
base okay you see that base then price
goes up then you have this very long
week okay and price potentially could go
all the way back to that base you know
consolidate a bit and then have another
move up. Okay, kind of like you know
base top base base top. Okay, something
like that is what I'll be looking at to
trade in this in this token. Okay, in
ENA and similar happens to I think it
was AAX or Rebax.
Yeah, pretty much you have the same
here. Okay, you go
in fact
you can see that this line goes even
further. Okay, you can see how it's been
tested as support, support, support,
support, resistance, resistance,
support, support, support, support.
Okay. So you can see that this white
dotted line it's an a level of interest
and you have the same you have here
some kind of bottom formation. Then
price goes up. You have a long week and
price is going to go again potentially
back to that level. Okay 1530 and in
that area around that area you could see
again some consolidation and price going
up again to 26. All right. If you
notice, this is pretty much some kind of
a of a range. Look at this yellow line
is the range slice. White of the line,
range lows. Okay, look at it.
Same all the time. All the time,
deviation above the range highs, back to
range lows. Okay, then retest
potentially back to the range highs. So,
these are the kind of setups that I'm
looking at and I hope that this video
was helpful. Um, it answers some some
questions. But again, keep an eye on the
king. Keep an eye on Bitcoin because all
the all the charts that I've showed you
are going to follow Bitcoin. Okay?
Again, potentially we are looking for a
move lower to 102K and more likely, you
know, sweep the lows of that long week
around 101K 100K. So, that's what we're
looking at. Then from there, you can
expect a new update from me and
potentially looking for new longs. All
right, so thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon.